das ist wirklich verrückt menschliches
leben 24 jahre lang eingefroren und
jetzt am leben können also menschen der
nächst eingefroren werden und jahrzehnte
ja jahrhunderte später aufwachen wenn
zum beispiel ihre unheilbare krankheit
geheilt werden kann
der weltrekord für ein gefrorenes
menschliches leben jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
emma brenn gibson ist ein sehr seltsames
bbs wurde als embryo eingefroren und
zwar vor 24 jahren am 14 oktober 1992
und am 25 november 2017 kam emma auf die
welt ihre mutter tina gibson die sie in
bunten hat ist heute 26 jahre alter sms
embryo eingefroren wurde war sie selbst
noch ein baby wie soll das bitte geh
jetzt mal langsam und ganz von vorne im
us geschichte beginnt also im oktober
1992 eine anonyme spenderin erklärt sich
bereit ihre bereits befruchteten
eizellen zur verfügung zu stellen
beispielsweise passiert das wenn die
eigene familienplanung abgeschlossen ist
die embryos entstehen bei der
sogenannten in vitro fertilisation hier
werden im labor eizelle und samenzelle
vereinigt der embryo kann dann in die
gebärmutter übertragen werden in den usa
gibt es aber eben auch die option den
embryo zunächst einmal einzufrieren
das alles läuft dann über bestimmte
kliniken wie beispielsweise dem national
education center im amerikanischen
knoxville in tennessee das motto
adoptiere einen embryo laut website sind
dadurch bereits mehr als 680 kinder
geboren worden
es gibt schätzungen nach denen alleine
in den usa bis zu einer million embryos
eingelagert sind sie werden auch als
snow babys also schnee babys bezeichnet
eine chance für menschen wie die
amerikanerin tina gibson und ihren mann
benjamin die sich unbedingt kinder
wünschen doch er ist an der
stoffwechselkrankheit mukoviszidose
erkannt und das steht ihrem kinderwunsch
im weg das paten im pflegekinder auf und
denkt über eine adoption nach doch dann
erfahren sie von der möglichkeit einen
embryo zu adoptieren die beiden dachten
lange darüber nach doch dann stand ihre
n
scheidung festina bekam entsprechende
medikamente und es gab viele gründliche
untersuchung um festzustellen ob solch
einen embryo einen transfer tatsächlich
klappen könnte zudem wurde auch die
familiäre situation und das zuhause der
gibsons sehr genau durchleuchtet eben um
zu schauen ob ein kind in diesem umfeld
vernünftig aufwachsen kann ähnlich wie
bei einer gewöhnlichen adoption im märz
2017 war es dann soweit der embryo wurde
in tinas gebärmutter eingesetzt die
ärzte erzählen sich die anekdote dass
sie damals wohl noch folgendes gesagt
hatte sie hätte meine beste freundin
sein können und tatsächlich das schnee
baby war im oktober 1992 gezeugt worden
und war somit bereits 24 eineinhalb
jahre eingefroren vorher hatte benjamin
aber tatsächlich die wahl aus etwa
dreihundert profilen unterschiedlicher
embryonen konnten sie auswählen dazu
tina es ist überwältigend es sind so
viele wonach wählt man aus
das paar entschied unter anderem dass es
ein kind werden sollte das als
erwachsener nicht besonders groß werden
wird denn auch die beiden sind eher
klein schließlich wurde tina dann ein
weiblicher embryo eingepflanzt deren
profil dem ehepaar gibson am besten
passte mit der schwangerschaft klappte
es dann sofort die neun monate verliefen
relativ unkompliziert weltrekord heißt
es jetzt überall doch tatsächlich ist es
gar nicht so einfach möglich die
ältesten bekannten embryos zu
identifizieren denn die unternehmen in
den usa sind lediglich dazu verpflichtet
das ergebnis der schwangerschaft nicht
aber das alter des embryos zu melden in
einer studie von 2011 jedenfalls wird
von einem 20 jahre alten embryo
berichtet den gibson ist das alles total
egal dazu tina ich wollte bloß ein baby
haben mir ist es egal ob es ein
weltrekord ist oder nicht
in medienberichten heißt es weiter dass
wohl auch geschwister für immer möglich
sein denn in der klinik seien sogar noch
weitere embryos mit genau dieser den
wenn ich exakt aber geschwister dna am
start aber ist das ein indiz dafür dass
wir in zukunft vielleicht menschen
einfrieren und wiederbeleben können ich
werde demnächst auf jeden fall darüber
berichten wenn ihr das video nicht
verpassen wollen und auch zu allen
anderen themen informiert werden wollt
dann drückt mir hier einen abo aufs auge
und vergessen nicht denen genau auf die
glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer
über neue videos informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dafür braucht gegen ewiges
leben möglich ja ansonsten bis dann